what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell the way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in and get yourself a
whim and shouldn't vote t-shirt today if
you are tired of the craziness tired of
all of these policies that women have
passed get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt today so you know guys when
I do these shows I really just like to
show common Trends in society
and I really want to show how in society
the men have gotten more feminine the
women have got more masculine and there
have been policies that oppress men
that have been passed by women that
really degrade the family unit and so
when I go through these stories what I'm
not trying to do is demonize anybody but
rather
show the consequences of our actions and
like what what these policies have
created you know we've talked about the
Logan Paul and Nina Agdal situation and
I will say you know Nina does she seems
like a really nice girl but the issue
was she was a model um in her early 20s
and you know spent her early 20s um late
20s around a bunch of celebrities
um really good looking chick dated a
bunch of guys and you know now it's
really biting her in the ass because now
she's dating Logan Paul and he's
fighting Dylan danis and Dylan danis
basically tweeting pictures of Nina
Agdal with other men every single day so
um there's been some updates in this
story so let's let's pull them up
so once the fight get in
October 14th chat let me know if this
happens man that's I don't know what to
do it's just [__] recorder every day
it's a law fair bro that's what they do
that's what the this always been the
primary weapon of the Matrix law fair
they just attack you with lawsuits they
try and drain you financially and try
and distract you it's endless I think
Rogan doesn't want Minister wolf I think
that's where I'm at right now I think he
doesn't want to play me I think he's
just trying to get me to get to pull out
somehow so then he looks like the hero
you know I don't know it's [__]
because this is all going through him
you know even if I win the case right I
still have to pay over four hundred
thousand dollars and just attorney fees
lawyer fees so it's like just [__]
when I'm promoting a fight this is the
biggest fight he's ever done and or
event he's ever done and I made the
whole event like it's just [__] man
well you did make the event interesting
I'll give you that
that's so funny yeah um basically now
Dylan danis has been served with a
lawsuit and guys this is a a comment I
would say Modern Woman an emotional man
tactic where if you're saying something
they don't like they typically Sue and
it's one thing if they're saying
something that's not true into faming
you and I you know I have mixed feelings
on defamation suits I guess part of me
thinks you know freedom of speech is
freedom of speech but at the same time
you can't go around saying something
that's not true but I mean all Dylan
danis did was post pictures that are
freely available on the internet
um so Dylan danis has tweeted between
lawsuits and snitching this [__] is a
straight up rat can't defend himself or
his hoe so he has to involve the law
what a coward
um so what do you guys think do you
think the lawsuit is Justified um my
take on it is
I I don't think it is I really think
that Logan did invite this by scheduling
the fight
but you know he wanted a troll and he
got a troll this is what he got it was
really interesting to see um Andrew Tate
and Dylan danis on a stream together I
thought they were so funny
um and Logan comes in he says
translation Predator see that's feminist
language all these words guys they're
just nonsense it's just feminism okay
Predator commits federal crime in
pursuit of stalking and harassing a
woman he's never met and is upset he's
held accountable
I did hear that he allegedly hacked her
Snapchat but I haven't seen any proof of
that Dylan danis says no federal crime
has been committed you're just listening
to the lives of your fiance in order to
save yourself image everything is public
and I will prove that it's not my fault
you didn't Google her name before you
put a ring on that thought and guys this
is the thing women are really really
good at manipulating men women like I
I don't know what she's telling him but
there's no way
there is no way you could talk your way
out of all of those I think he he
pictured her with like 50 something men
so Dylan danis responds and said I'm
actually flattered that she thinks I'm
smart enough to hack a Snapchat and also
as if years ago I knew they were going
to get married and kept them for this
moment okay so he's denying the Snapchat
allegations yeah I mean that does seem
far and what you see is lawsuit a lot of
lawsuits not all
um are really women just policing men
talking he into someone's had an
interesting take on it so let's pull it
up currently influencer Logan Paul is
scheduled to meet up with MMA fighter
Dylan danis on October 14
2023 not a big deal obviously there was
some trolling going back and forth but
then things sort of took a turn I would
say when Logan Paul decided to make a
comment on Dylan danis's girlfriend now
this is only relevant because Logan Paul
recently got engaged to Nina Agdal and I
want to talk about Nina Agdal and it's
in her entirety because I have known
Nina Agdal I have followed in the AG
doll I think Nina AG doll is absolutely
beautiful and Nina Agdal prior to
getting involved and she she didn't
herself say anything to Dylan Dennis but
prior to because of her attachment to
Logan Paul being inserted into this
fight was considered someone that I
think most people assumed was a high
value woman now why is this because she
is an actual supermodel she is a woman
that has walked the runway of Victoria's
Secret she notoriously dated Leonardo
DiCaprio I would say that was kind of
her first introduction to publicity it
seems to be some sort of a rite of
passage with supermodels obviously we
know Gisele Bundchen so think of her in
that Bay News Albanian people that have
dated Leonardo DiCaprio for a year I
don't know they age out when they're 22
or 23 he breaks up with them and they go
on to have an amazing career as a
supermodel Ina AG doll for all of
intents and purposes was one of these
women she has tons of sponsorships tons
of deals she also now operates her own
fitness program that's called the AG
doll method that is the reason why I
began following her because I love
Fitness obviously and this was a model
that was very much getting involved in
the Fitness World setting up studios in
the Hamptons and hosting classes when
Logan Paul decided to make a comment
regarding Dylan Dennis's other
well this is when things got really bad
for Nina Agdal I want to express that I
do actually feel bad for her all right I
don't think Nina Agdal is a bad person
and a lot of the clips that he Unearthed
that I don't think a lot of people had
seen uh or at least I don't think that
people had seen in such a rapid
progression are older she looks quite
young in these clips she looks to be
doing what I always talk about a lot of
women experiment with feminism in their
youth except a lot of those women don't
have cameras in front of them don't have
Instagrams don't have any level of Fame
and so they're able to grow up and say
you know what actually a lot of that
stuff was really trashy and I don't
actually believe those things I was just
doing what everybody else was doing
because it was popular and cultural in
that moment Nina Agdal is not a sex
worker Nina Agdal is not on only fans
selling her body she is a person that
was respected for being a supermodel and
respected for being a fitness model as
well for running as a small business
owner a company out in New York that is
training women to train their bodies all
of that right is now being impacted
because people are seeing her in a new
light so this is humiliating Fina Agdal
right this is a person that is being
impacted for the rest of her life what's
going to happen now if you don't think
this is impacting Logan Paul you're out
of your mind because men are mocking him
men are mocking him because they are
basically saying that your woman is
available to all of us look at all these
videos right they have demeaned her and
they have devalued her in the public
sphere so it's interesting how she said
they devalued her
it's like injured people have like
language slips sometimes they said they
devalued her in the public sphere but
really like she devalued herself in the
public sphere
um I do agree with what she's saying
where you know a lot of the a lot of the
wives of the previous generation would
have had similar Clips but there was no
cameras back in the day and you know
this is why I always say the truth
really does come out eventually sooner
or later and you know Candace is right
to be honest not everything that That
Glitters Is Gold and a lot of times you
you see you know men thinking they're
signing up for one thing and they and
they get another and guys I hate to say
it but this is why men like younger
women
so it'll be interesting to see we're
getting closer and closer to the fight
so I'm actually really excited to see it
so one thing that's interesting being in
Europe so I live for those of you that
don't know I do live in England
um and I'm an American I'm from Chicago
and I moved to England and I've lived in
England um I was recruited to play
volleyball I started the podcast things
just kind of took off so being here the
interesting thing is that you get to see
a lot of differences culturally you know
London is such a diverse place my Lord
it is like the most diverse place I've
ever lived like you can talk to people
from Spain you can talk to people from
Italy Nigeria Pakistan like London has
it is truly a Melting Pot okay and
coming here I I have to say I heard a
lot of things about women in other
countries being very different
um where you're not going to find this
Western mentality and I have to be
honest guys I was a bit disappointed
um I actually found that women that came
from Spain Italy Africa once they got to
the UK a lot of them developed the same
mindset you know I I've interviewed men
that dated women from Poland and were
screwed over in divorce court that dated
women from Africa were screwed over in
divorce court that really like if they
come to the West it's kind of the same
thing but you know one country that I've
heard that the women are
more modest and feminine and better
wives in is Japan now I did I did have
one girl um from Japan on my team and
she she was nice but I don't
I don't remember anything in particular
that different I guess but
um
it's interesting to see Americans going
to Japan and talking about their
experience so there's one article that I
remember I read a couple of weeks ago of
a woman going to Japan and talking about
how the men just found her to be
invisible
she's like I have been on a date in
three years
yeah they're not they're not with this
and I think it's because you know the
men they are maybe don't tolerate it
they don't they're not with that [__] in
Japan and here's a clip of a woman
talking about some of the cultural
differences being an American moving to
Japan
if you are coming to Japan and planning
on going to the gym let me just warn you
do not wear a matching set do not wear a
cute little outfit like this I know that
we all love them I feel so super cute
right now but if I wear something like
this to the gym Japanese people
literally treat me like I have a [__]
written on my forehead like they stop
and they look at me and they're like
what the [__] like I've forgotten to get
dressed this is how I dress now now that
I've been living here for a year when I
go to the gym this is how I dress like
all the other Japanese people
not [__] kidding you this is the vibe
this is the vibe
okay and the pants with the leggings on
underneath this is the look that we go
for
okay I couldn't feel less hot I couldn't
feel less like working out than in this
but if I wear the other thing then
people literally stop what they're doing
and look at me
so this is the vibe so if you come to
Japan just be prepared yep
no it's so true because even the first
outfit I'm like that's almost modest in
2023 you see these chicks in like
nothing you know and even me like I grew
up playing volleyball so what do you
wear in volleyball you wear Spandex and
I was thinking about how weird that is
how they literally put like 10 11 12
year old chicks in Spanish isn't it
they're kind of weird I was thinking
about this
um but you're so used to it as a
volleyball player you don't even think
much of it but
you know in Japan
modesty is encouraged femininity is
encouraged the one thing I don't
understand about Japan though is their
their birth rate is so low so it'd be
interesting I wish I could talk to some
people that are actually like from Japan
that could tell me like why the birth
rate is so low there because they're
they're they're
um they really do have an aging like an
aging population okay so for the rest of
the show guys I actually kind of wanted
to go back in time so you know there's
been a little bit of a transition in the
channel um and I want I wanted to talk
to you guys about it so a year ago I was
doing four shows a week so I would do
four live shows where I would bring in
people
um usually like five to ten guys and
girls and we would have discussions
about modern relationships and dating
um we'd also mix in political content
like I would do shows about like why I'm
pro-life or whatever topic I wanted to
talk about that week I would do a show
um guys that schedule just killed me I
was up all night I just couldn't do it I
I so recently you know I still do the
shows but I just do them once a week so
I do them Thursday nights tune in you
know that's what I'm doing a live show
here
and I started the shows with a slightly
different mentality you know I didn't
realize
just a couple things about female nature
I didn't realize how easily influenced
we were
um I didn't realize how much of a hive
mind we have you know and yeah I was
influenced so much by this that that
that's what made me come to the
conclusion that women should have vote
was honestly your shows you know doing
this documentary where I interview men
that have been wrecked in divorced and
also interviewing the women of today
that will go on to wreck these men in
divorce
um you know because most of them aren't
married it's mostly single people
um I just I came to like a lot of
different I don't know conclusions from
the show
um so it's really interesting because
when you go back through my old content
you sort of see me getting like red
pilled in real time
um because at first I would watch the
content I would sort of take it in and
it's different when you're watching it
versus when you're like experiencing it
in real life and a lot of people thought
that we casted or um only got the
craziest women for shows and you know I
mean
there's maybe you might if there's a a
crazy guest you might invite them more
than once but guys it is so difficult to
get that many people in in a week we
have cancellations all the time you just
can't oh there's no way there's no way
you can cast it um not with the budget I
had so there was a clip of mine going
viral from one of my old shows and I
actually wanted to talk about what I
learned from this clip still say things
like men are trash Society hates that
look at everything on TV it's always the
dumb Dad what's on The Simpsons the guy
doing something stupid the woman coming
to the rescue women are Queens women
empowerment women women there's no men's
empowerment men disappear tomorrow and
society would collapse men built the
world that we complain about all the
hard jobs are done by men who's a better
companion men or women men can be alone
women can't you don't see women going
out to the woods and just roughing it
that's a man thing all the women
disappeared tomorrow men would be fine
outside of reproduction men don't need
women women need them
all right so a lot of people think I
have extreme opinions but I realize that
sometimes I say things and people don't
understand how I got to those
conclusions
um so this was through hundreds of shows
looking at data research and just
listening to men talk a lot of the time
okay and women and women talk
when I looked and what I realized was
when I looked into the data men
disproportionately did all of the hard
jobs
everything
they built the buildings
um they are most of the police force
most of the factory jobs and women by
and large had easier jobs you know you
can't convince me that education
daycare workers and human resources
which are predominantly women is equally
as hard as Plumbing electricity
and Paving the roads you can't there is
nothing that will convince me of this so
when I had this realization that men
really make the world run
and what do they get in return and I I
thought about how bad of a deal men are
getting
because even though you might say like
and I've heard a lot of podcasts say
this like men are losers nowadays
and when I looked into the data and um I
have I have a friend that helps me
research on this but when we included
like factory jobs truckers
um police officers as the infrastructure
of society the military
uh half of men are in a job that runs
Society it absolutely makes it run and I
thought about what they get as a thank
you and I thought huh
so as a thank you the women [__] on the
men and call them trash
that that's what they get
and it actually made me sad to think
about how unappreciative women as a
whole are of men and how little they get
in return and you would think that maybe
they would get a wife and kids but okay
maybe they don't get a wife and kids all
right but at least men used to know that
they would get respect there were some
basic Baseline respect you would get
from just being a man and when I heard
that
men run Society I never really thought
about it like that but you know then
when Kevin Samuels I think was the first
person I heard explain this when I heard
him say that I thought huh he's
absolutely right they do what do women
do in society not much
um I mean
if you count the the mothers that are
addicted to like wine
I mean how many like crackhead mothers
do we have
so I want to go to the next lesson I
learned so I think that that clip was
from last summer but I actually want to
rewind a little bit before that so about
a year and a half ago
um at this point this was super early
show and you're gonna see just how low
the production was the mics were peaking
it's it's not it's not great production
value this is when I did it you know but
this show I actually brought in athletes
so I I was recruited here to play
volleyball and what what happened is
there's actually a professional
basketball team around where I used to
live so these are
um the women's team is some of the best
basketball players I I played basketball
in college best basketball players I
have ever seen in my life they are they
are so talented I'm talking like one
percent of one percent this woman
actually played in the Olympics and I
actually brought them over to have a
discussion and I I don't even think this
was the topic so this this basketball
player is the epitome of feminism female
sports is just feminism and it really
leads you to be single child listen
alone unfortunately I love female sports
but I'm just I'm just being honest so
you see her world view crashing down
when I tell her that women deserve less
money
because they don't do as much work but
even when it comes to sports right the
only sport that is paid the exactly
though no but I'm saying yes
that's because respectfully I know men
are better than women at sports sorry
I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry you're probably you
you specifically you're probably better
than most men but in general like most
men in the NBA can dunk WNBA can't and
they and they get paid more because they
make more money like that like women's
NCAA has been at a loss for years they
don't even make money
why is that because because people don't
watch as much because it's just not as
entertaining who's I don't even keep who
runs the show who who's the top dog the
man because every time
is I really want to watch a women's game
like I would watch a women's game like
that when it gets to like
certain levels like finals semi-finals I
like I watch it but like
this is like and I'm a sports person so
like imagine people like that aren't
like it's sad it's sad because listen if
I was a woman I would [__] hate men
I'd be like the feminists like
on an individual level what we're gonna
do is the people
just one second just that fact in itself
what you're saying do you know what I
mean and that is why there's those women
groups because of these situations it's
so hard for us to get jobs and then you
add race into it you add where you live
ethnicity all these things are so
difficult so yeah there are only women
in clubs that are only women gyms oh no
there's not meant because there's Dirty
Old Men Who wank in the corner that
comes into that yeah there's things all
put in for women because for so many
years they've been
devalued like how are how are we
devalued we got to stay at home and not
work that [__] sounds awesome
but I'm saying like like like even even
the women but that was only keep that
came from like the war days where the
women had jobs in the war and then the
men came home and then they took those
women's jobs so then they got put back
in the home of now you have to live well
like historically men had to fight in
war so how can we say we were oppressed
we never had to fight in Wars
let's talk about the pay Gap like the
reason that women are paid more than
women is because they pick industries
that make more money
so like like if you go to the most
egalitarian countries in the world where
women have more Choice the the pay Gap
is bigger
it's so funny it got I don't like I
don't like that guy in the back I forgot
I forgot his name but he was kind of
simping he's like well it's because of
the guys at the top now you know damn
well it's not because of the guys at the
top and this is what I mean like they'll
kind of guys will kind of say it to be
nice but so what do we learn here
this woman
has made it to be an elite athlete one
of the most successful basketball
players in the world she played in the
Olympics
and yet for some reason she's made it to
her mid-30s and still thinks that women
are oppressed
how do we and and I I genuinely think
that she believes it
how do we make it to this old in life
believing a lie it's because this is
where this is where
I look back it's because the simp right
there co-signed it
and women will say this to other women
and nobody checks them
even I wish it's interesting looking
back because I didn't know as much about
the history but uh
she she looked at women working in
factories and the men took their jobs
after they came back from war it's like
[__] do you want to work in a factory
but
like is that is that what we want to do
so so I continued this journey further
you see it's so interesting you guys are
going to see like the production value
just go up and up and up this was at my
old apartment so I was literally just
living in this one bedroom apartment it
was so funny I um I was in England
playing volleyball and I was just doing
reactions on the side and I just thought
to myself you know I'm just gonna do
shows a couple days a week it's easy
enough
it's not as easy as I thought I was like
I'll just bring over some chicks from
the gym some girls in my volleyball team
whatever and we'll just have a
conversation with some mics all right
that's that's what I did I did not
expect to be here I didn't expect it to
get this big
um but I want to show you another you
know world view crashing down so it's
silly to think that a bad culture
wouldn't poison a woman
when left to our own devices
um okay so this was um last summer I
think yeah this was last summer let's so
let's pull up the let's pull up the clip
but I'm saying well is it fair that
women expect it over a certain age
that's the question
because you give your best years to
someone else
she's talking about going into a new
relationship yeah I know but if you're
going to a new relationship and say this
is the car and the car has been used for
the last 15 years
who said that we gave our best to
someone else I don't even know my
maximum or my best probably I never done
to to No One my best because I don't
know I give honestly I Loved Someone
before I don't know if I get the maximum
I can I don't know maybe I'm gonna find
tomorrow men are gonna give actually the
best of myself who said that I already
gave to someone else it's about what
they think's the best it's not about you
because you're not the one buying so the
guy the guy I think is the best man yes
from the event from the ages of 20 to 80
all think that girls are the most
attractive around 22 to 24. but like
this is a man that cannot stand on his
own like honestly because if you
honestly think that you can't stand on
his own yeah because like they actually
mind about what other people think
because if you're telling me that after
like men for their standards that's
shame it's shame and so guilt need to be
no that's just my point of view I'm
saying that I don't have an inspired day
that doesn't mean that after because I
add six-year uh relationship I gave my
best to someone no like if a man think
this it means that he's not that
confident to like get my best because if
you are a proper man you're gonna get my
best but see that's Shameless you're
saying like I'm beautiful no no no
I'll tell you why because you're saying
if you're a real man if you're a proper
man then you would think like me and you
know this woman is 35 years old
it thinks that she could compete with
the 20 year old are you stupid I'm not
trying to be rude but I'm like nobody
thinks you're 20. and you know I think
it was at this point
where I kind of was starting to realize
that we're all the same
yes yes well there are exceptions but
not really
um because you know even the men in the
room were still kind of co-signing it
they're like oh you're an exception
usually not no usually not
um you know she did I remember thinking
she looked young but 20
really 20. I mean
okay okay
um but the the sad thing is it's like
these women have been lied and misled
because they're told they we have all
the time in the world and the truth of
the matter is you don't and the truth of
the matter is a 20 year old is gonna
beat a 30 year old any day of the week
um there's exceptional 30 year olds that
maybe can outperform but it's definitely
not the rule and the problem is until
Kevin Samuels Russian fit and myself a
lot of people had never heard this like
they had never heard and it's
interesting how the women how the women
would say it's so awful that you would
say something like that but they never
say that you're wrong
they never say you're wrong they say
it's awful that you would say something
like that because at 35 I mean at that
point you kind of have to assume you're
it's not likely you're gonna get married
and have kids
what does this lead to so it's like the
last 10 years women we've just been so
addicted to social media right we've
just been crazy addicted and we just go
nutty I don't know why
um and then you start to see what
happens to these wives and mothers that
are working mothers
um and Kim Kardashian actually went
viral
um with a picture with her daughter
North and there's the painting and it
says Kim Kardashian shares a landscape
painting made by North now North clearly
is going to be a genius like she's
absolutely going to be a genius this is
Kanye's this is Kanye's daughter and
she's so beautiful and the sad thing is
is you see her being ruined by her
mother in front of her eyes
this is not good for a kid being on
social media like that is absolutely
terrible for a kid and it is not fair it
is absolutely not fair to children to
have them paraded on social media
without asking their permission like
imagine being 18 or 16 whenever you
start to like remember things and your
mom your dad's been Plastering you on
social media and profiting off of you
for 10 years
you know I think parents are supposed to
they're supposed to look out for their
kids and you know there's a lot of
predators online that's a conversation
we don't want to talk about a lot of
predators and a lot of parents are
putting their kids in nefarious
situations by Plastering them on social
media but what did I notice here
um Kim's sticking her chest out you know
I could take a selfie right but when
you're taking a selfie in your in your
your boobs are out uh this woman is
thirst trapping with her daughter
this is this is what happens when you
you spend your entire life
living for the media this is what
happens and without a masculine
Authority presence
this I this should be shamed this should
be taken down and I think this is why
men should have primary custody
say what you want about yay but he was
the one saying that his kids shouldn't
be on social media and Kim routinely has
them dancing to music about sex she had
her in a video with ice spice and now
she's thirst strapping with her daughter
you know some things are just meant to
be private with your family and I think
children are one of them you know I
don't say these things to you know
hate anybody I don't I certainly don't
hate women as much as they want to say I
do I just think we have to look at
societal Trends and what are the
outcomes of societal Trends and on the
show guys I have heard Kim Kardashian's
name like an ungodly amount of times an
ungodly amount of times because women
see her as an idol I mean
um she released the sex tape and then
got not one not two but three high
volume men to marry her
now the truth of the matter is women
like that will get married but they
usually die alone because they just
overplay their hand they start to get
delusional
um you know beauty beauty is the most
valuable thing in the world I mean who
else can become a billionaire from
having sex
I mean
um look at look at Bill Gates's wife
billionaire just from having sex with a
guy it is a valuable commodity and and
this is the thing ladies women
do get away with stuff okay they do all
the time they'll continue to get away
with stuff but most women aren't as hot
as Kim Kardashian they're not they're
not going to and Kim Kardashian probably
still gonna die alone you know
um but you know let me know what you
guys think in the comments
um like the video make sure you
subscribe to the channel and let me know
what you want me to cover next week make
sure you get a women shoot a vote
t-shirt today I will talk to you guys
next time